Moviegoers of all ages probably
recognize Joe Pesci from his streetwise,
fast-talking performances in films
like "Goodfellas" and "Home Alone."
Pesci has stayed mostly out of the
spotlight since the turn of the millennium,
but that doesn't mean he's disappeared
entirely. Here is the untold truth of Joe Pesci.
Born Joseph Frank Pesci on February 9, 1943 in
Newark, New Jersey, Joe Pesci was thrown into the
spotlight at an early age by his father, Angelo,
who saw show business as a ticket to giving his
family a better life. By the time he was five
years old, Pesci made his debut on "Star Time
Kids," a television variety series that aired from
1950 to 1955. The experience was, by Pesci's own
description, less than pleasurable: in a 1992
interview with The New York Times, he said,
"My father loved me so much that he did
not want me to be a laborer or anything.
I don't know if it's the right thing to
do — push your kids into something and
then stay on them until they do it.
Let them pick what they want to do."
Though Pesci was less than enthused about
performing, it kept him afloat during his
pre-fame days. Pesci sang and played guitar in a
string of pop and rock acts, most notably in the
touring version of the popular New York act Joey
Dee and the Starliters, which provided him with
his first feature film appearance as an extra
in the band's star vehicle, "Hey, Let's Twist!"
Pesci then made his bid for pop stardom in
1968 with the release of his first solo album,
"Little Joe Sure Can Sing!" But the LP wasn't a
hit, so he returned to gigging alongside another
Jersey musician, Frank Vincent. However, live club
music had fallen out of fashion by the early '70s,
so the pair turned to comedy,
forming the duo Vincent and Pesci.
"I'm funny how, you mean I'm funny like a
clown, like I amuse you? I make you laugh?"
Decades after they hung up the act,
Vincent would remain Pesci's friend
off-camera and frequent nemesis on film: Pesci
brutalized Vincent in "Raging Bull" and beat him
to death in "Goodfellas," while Vincent returned
the favor by bashing in Pesci's skull in "Casino."
In 1976, Pesci had his first credited movie role
in "Family Enforcer," also known as "The Death
Collector," a low-budget Mafia thriller starring
Pesci and Joe Cortese as muscle for the Mob.
Solid reviews prompted Pesci to head
to Hollywood, but a lack of further
success sent him packing back to the Bronx,
where he worked as a restaurant manager.
It was at this low point that Martin
Scorsese and Robert De Niro came calling;
the director and star had seen Pesci in "Family
Enforcer" and sought him out for their next
project, the boxing drama "Raging Bull." Pesci
played Joey LaMotta, the brother, manager,
and eventual enemy of short-tempered boxer Jake
LaMotta, which earned him a nomination for Best
Supporting Actor at the Oscars the following
year and made his name one to remember.
From 1980 to 1998, Pesci lent his unique
charm to a handful of iconic movies,
from Scorcese collaborations such as "Goodfellas''
and "Casino" to comedies like "Home Alone" and "My
Cousin Vinny." He had a small part opposite De
Niro in the legendary Sergio Leone's last film,
"Once Upon a Time in America," portrayed
real-life pilot David Ferrie in "JFK,"
and had a recurring role as Leo Getz
in the "Lethal Weapon" franchise.
However, many of Pesci's credits are likely
to be total obscurities to even the most
seasoned moviegoers. For instance,
in 1983, Pesci starred as a bowling
alley owner with dreams of stardom in the
West German musical "Dear Mr. Wonderful."
It's also likely that you missed Pesci as
the uncle of the bride in "Betsy's Wedding,"
or his thinly veiled take on legendary
photographer Weegee in "The Public Eye."
The takeaway? Pesci's hits are very big, but
his misses disappear, with little in between.
Pesci has given few interviews since announcing
his retirement, so his reasons for the decision
remain solely with him. However, it's possible
that he simply lost his taste for the projects
that were being offered to him. As far back
as 1992, Pesci told The New York Times that
many of the roles brought to him were, quote,
"stupid, ethnic Italian parts [with] pizza-pie
stupid jokes." While he mostly avoided that
characterization in his film work, Pesci did
withstand a barrage of jokes about his height
in the dismal NBC action-comedy "Half Nelson."
Pesci was top-billed as Rocky Nelson, an NYPD
detective who works for a private security firm
while trying to launch an acting career.
The series, co-created by Glen A. Larson,
paired Pesci with "Saturday Night Live" alum
Victoria Jackson as a scatterbrained secretary,
former football player Fred Williamson as Rocky's
boss, and a visibly unwell Dean Martin as himself.
At the time of its release, critic David
Handler described "Half Nelson" as, quote,
"[managing] to leave you
feeling both bored and soiled,"
which undoubtedly helped capsize the
series after just seven episodes.
Joe Pesci's Oscar win for his portrayal of
gangster Tommy DeVito in "Goodfellas" helped
to wipe away any residue from "Half Nelson" or his
other early obscurities, and it's likely that he
saw his win as the start of a new and improved
phase of his career. He told The New York Times,
"I love to star in movies, but I want
to have good roles. It doesn't help to
get starring roles in something that's no
good. I mean, that will just kill you."
Although he netted several box office hits, much
of his output during the 1990s was dismissed by
critics and audiences alike. Attempts to fashion
Pesci into a comedic leading man in "The Super"
and "Gone Fishin'" were busts, as was his attempt
at tugging heartstrings in the terminally soggy
"With Honors," which cast him as a homeless man
with a big heart and a scholar's brain. By 1998,
Pesci had clearly lost his patience with
the industry: after logging his third and
final turn as machine gun-mouthed Leo Getz in
"Lethal Weapon 4" — which earned him a Razzie
nomination — he retired from acting as a full-time
profession and focused his energies elsewhere.
"I'm sorry, okay, okay, okay,
okay! Whatever, whatever!"
With several notable exceptions, Pesci mostly
stuck to his decision to put acting on the back
burner. Instead, he focused his energy
on golf and, to the surprise of many,
went back to singing. In 1998, Pesci released
his second album, "Vincent LaGuardia Gambini
Sings Just for You," named for his character
in "My Cousin Vinny." Despite his ill-advised
pass at hip-hop with the infamous single "Wise
Guy," Pesci still proved his musical prowess
with renditions of "What a Wonderful World" and
the Ray Charles number "I've Got News For You."
Although critics and listeners alike largely
dismissed the album as a vanity project, Pesci
kept his hand in music. As "Joe Doggs," he earned
respectable reviews for "Falling in Love Again," a
collaboration with jazz organist Joey DeFrancesco,
and held his own alongside his onetime idol,
Little Jimmy Scott, on "The Folks Who Live on
the Hill," a duet featured on the legendary
vocalist's final studio album, "I Go Back Home."
Two years later, Pesci released his third album,
"Still Singing," which featured two
duets with Maroon 5's Adam Levine.
In a 2016 interview, comedy legend Don Rickles,
who appeared with Pesci in
"Casino," said of his co-star,
"I think sometimes he believed he was
with the Mob. But he got over it."
Given Pesci's multitude of terrifying gangster
performances, it's understandable how some might
misconstrue him as a made man in the real
world. While there are tales of the actor
interacting with career criminals, Pesci has kept
himself out of trouble offscreen. Well, mostly.
In 2006, Pesci was involved in an alleged
assault against an overzealous fan in Florida.
According to a police report, Pesci struck a man
who ignored his request to refrain from taking
his picture, but prosecutors dismissed
the allegations over a lack of evidence.
A half-decade later, Pesci was involved in
not one, but two legal cases: the first,
in 2012, involved his ex-wife, actress
Claudia Haro, who was sentenced to 12
years for allegedly hiring a hitman to whack
her second husband, stuntman Garrett Warren.
Pesci was briefly considered as the supposed
source of financing for the failed hit,
though the allegations were eventually dismissed.
The following year, Pesci was awarded an
unspecified court settlement from Fiore Pictures
after he sued the company for allegedly reducing
his salary and role in what would become the
infamous 2018 biopic "Gotti" with John Travolta.
There's no question that Joe
Pesci is a complicated individual.
Even he's noted as much: in an
interview with the Baltimore Sun,
he recalled having an existential crisis
while playing a game of golf, saying:
"I didn't know who the hell was about
to hit that golf ball. Was it Leo Getz
or David Ferrie or Tommy or Harry or Joe?
I've spent so much time as somebody else,
and so little time as myself, I lost
sight of who I was for an instant."
Pesci is an enormously talented actor, and
if his quietly menacing performance in "The
Irishman" is any indication, one still capable
of mesmerizing audiences well into his 70s.
However, he seems to prefer to focus
on other outlets that appear to have a
greater hold on his heart, including singing
and tending to his own personal well-being.
If acting has left him feeling
misunderstood, misrepresented,
and even unsure of who he really is, it's hard
to blame him for choosing to step away from it.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.